Halle Berry and her husband get a
divorce
ultimatum the court has demanding they
finally make a decision go through with
that or call the divorce off here's the
thing Nancy they filed almost a year ago
but since then radio silence so could a
reconciliation be in the warped end
where in the world has Olivier been
living here's what a source is telling
us exclusively olivia has been living in
one of three homes which Haile owns in
Los Angeles right now there are real
main focuses on their children they have
an almost three-year-old son together
Masayo and then of course there's
eight-year-old Nala whoo holly has with
her ex Gabriel Aubry the court doc
titled notice of case review default was
filed September 1st
it gives Halle and Olivier three options
one move forward with the divorce to
file a dismissal or three the court can
dismiss based on default one of the
things that led to both of them filing
for divorce last October was anger
management issues everyone remembers
when Olivia shoved at LAX worker with
the BBC and of course he also got into
that Thanksgiving brawl with Gabriel
that left the model knocked up pretty
badly but now we're hearing that Olivier
McCauley are not fighting as much
anymore
just last March the pair with the kids
vacationed together in Mexico and Halle
who turned 50 last month has been active
on Instagram showing off her bikini body
and just flat-out enjoying life so will
the couple reconciled not so fast
a source tells us the divorces quote
definitely still happening not sure
about why paperwork is slow now this
divorce ultimatum is nothing new in
Hollywood Patrick Dempsey got one last
May he and wife Jillian have since
reconciles Gweneth of course got one in
February and she finalized her divorce
from Chris Martin 21 weeks later
basically this court ultimatum is a way
for the courts to say dismiss this or
move on and there's no penalty the stars
do nothing